[Música]
Bienvenidos a enlace Norteamérica desde
Ciudad de México hoy abordaremos el
vuelco que ha dado el caso Ayotzinapa al
cumplirse 8 años de la desaparición de
43 estudiantes en el Estado de Guerrero
la investigación ha dado un giro y altos
funcionarios han sido encarcelados pero
la exigencia de los padres sigue siendo
la misma conocer el paradero de los
jóvenes
[Música]
ocho años después de la desaparición de
43 alumnos de la Escuela Normal Rural de
Ayotzinapa la fiscalía general de la
república y la comisión para la verdad y
acceso a la justicia de este caso han
determinado que se trató de un crimen de
estado la llamada verdad histórica ha
sido enterrada por las actuales
autoridades si Bien dicen no tener
indicios para considerar que los jóvenes
estén aún con vida los padres ven lentos
los avances y demandan respuestas
concretas está estas fechas el gobierno
mexicano reconoce que es un crimen de
estado entonces que está esperando para
accionar no a este y habla una parte de
verdad de unas capturas de que los
jóvenes estarían sido este asesinados
verdad pero pues como decir muchas cosas
sin antes ahondar una investigación a
fondo entonces falta mucho que
esclarecer para nosotros falta mucho el
compromiso del presidente tiene que ser
un poco más este que intervenga un poco
más él a la Cómo va la investigación
avanzando tras una exhaustiva
reconstrucción de los hechos el informe
de la comisión para la verdad Establece
que el 26 de septiembre de 2014 los
estudiantes tomaron autobuses para
trasladarse a la Ciudad de México y
participar en la conmemoración de la
matanza estudiantil del 2 de octubre de
1968 pero fueron atacados por policías
de varios municipios y entregados a
sicarios del grupo delictivo Guerreros
Unidos quienes los habrían confundido
con rivales las autoridades tienen
evidencias de que los jóvenes fueron
ultimados nosotros no podemos vivir en
nuestros hijos porque pues estamos
pensando a dónde estarán que estaban
haciendo porque ellos saben uno de los
cielos para nuestros hijos yo me tengo
fe 22 y yo como madre del hijo José Luis
lona Torres para mí yo sé que amigo está
vivo y ellos saben donde los tiene
porque ellos los detuvieron vivos ellos
nos han querido engañar con cosas que
que no son Jesús Murillo procurador de
justicia en el sexenio de Enrique Peña y
autor de la cuestionada verdad histórica
fue detenido en agosto pasado y recluido
en prisión acusado de tortura
desaparición forzada y obstrucción de la
justicia el 21 de Septiembre cinco días
antes del octavo aniversario de la
tragedia un juez Federal dictó formal
prisión contra 4 militares entre ellos
el General José Ramírez Pérez quien
comandaba el Batallón de Infantería en
Iguala Al momento de los hechos en 2014
son estas las detenciones de más alto
nivel pero las familias exigen ir a
fondo tope donde tope debe haber una
investigación exhaustiva no a fondo no y
de toda la jerarquía militar de todo a
quien aquel que le resulta
responsabilidad aquí hay muchas
responsabilidades aquí se tiene Ellos
tienen a salvo probatorio ahí que lo han
administrado y no lo han aportado la
autoridad porque las razones nosotros
desconocemos Y desde ahí ya están
incurriendo en responsabilidad penal
incluso la fiscalía notificó a la
secretaría de la defensa Nacional de las
20 órdenes de aprehensión que hay contra
elementos del ejército presuntamente
involucrados en la desaparición de los
jóvenes mientras que uno de los
principales implicados Tomás Cerón Quien
fuera jefe de la agencia de
investigación criminal y señalado de
fabricar pruebas sigue en Israel prófugo
de la justicia
continuamos de manera puntual
acompañando a la unidad especial para la
investigación del caso de la fiscalidad
general República en todo el proceso de
extradición de Tomás Cerón del estado de
Israel y quiero informar que seguimos
acopiando mayor información
mayores evidencias
continuamos con la labores de búsqueda
de los muchachos y en su oportunidad
presentaremos un segundo informe en
siete municipios de Guerrero se han
realizado más de 100 acciones de
búsqueda en esas jornadas han hallado
más de mil restos socios y 32 de ellos
fueron enviados a laboratorio genético
de la Universidad de innsbruck Sin
embargo hasta ahora solo se han
identificado los restos de tres de los
desaparecidos los mismos de los que ya
se sabía por lo que los padres y
compañeros de las víctimas seguirán
alzando la voz en en las calles
Gracias por acompañarnos el enlace
Norteamérica desde Ciudad de México soy
Mario carbonell y mi compañera en cámara
Lizeth Romero Hasta pronto